si on a tous un pote qui connaît l'ami
d'un frère qui travaille pour un
ministère et qui a des infos exclusives
difficile d'obtenir des informations
fiables sur ce qui devrait nous arriver
dans les prochaines semaines couvre-feu
à 15h confinement généralisée
confinement le week-end plus de
confinement du tout difficile de
répondre à ces questions
à y regarder les chiffres d'un peu plus
près il est vrai que les nouvelles ne
sont pas des plus rassurantes les
chiffres de se dégradent les chiffres
évidemment du virus avec 22 1848 cas
supplémentaires et 346 mort en 24 heures
une courbe qui repart à la hausse et une
question qui revient dans toutes les
têtes
va-t-on être confiné patrick peloux
merci d'être là patrick merci savais que
je vous aime beaucoup
gbr énormément je suis très heureux que
vous soyez là je sais que vous êtes très
très inquiet de la situation
vous tenez à alerter les personnes qui
nous regardent ce soir c'est vrai qu'on
est extrêmement regardez il ya beaucoup
de jeunes qui nous regardent et pour
faire clair vous n'êtes pas très
optimiste qu'est-ce qui se passe non il
se passe que si vous voulez on est sur
un schéma qui est très inquiétant parce
qu'en fait il ya un an quand tout a
commencé
on s'est tous dit on est avec un virus
qui va faire un tour de manège et qu'il
va s'en aller ce qui a été inquiétant
c'était à peu près vers le mois de mai
où on a vu arriver des variants voilà
les variants en fait on a fait
et un peu de gens on les voit pas les
variants sont bien art ni hal varian
anglais dont vous parlez régulièrement
il ya le variant brésilien qui pose
problème et surtout le sud africain qui
pose problème plus tout ce qu'on n'a pas
encore identifié
j'étais de garde cette nuit au samu de
paris est en fait l'épidémie reprend
pour ce qui est de paris d'accord on
avait quasiment zéro cas ces dernières
semaines on a 20 % d'activité sur le co
vide
cette nuit c'est pas gai c'est pas gai
parce que ça veut dire que probablement
on est avec une véritable nouvelle
maladie sur terre il est en train de
muter qui est en train d'évoluer comme
évolue le virus qu'on connaît tous
depuis des depuis toujours et on sait
pas trop où on va
est-ce qu'il est plus contagieux ou
est-ce qu'il est plus bon il est plus
contagieux et pas plus dangereux
d'accord pour l'instant pour l'instant
mais il faut pas faire peur mais pour
l'instant si vous voulez on n'est pas
sur la situation de ce qu'on a connu en
mars ou en fait les chinois nous avait
donné de mauvaises informations dont on
consomme on a pataugé là on a eu le
travail notamment des réanimateurs
médicaux des infectiologues des
pneumologues et c'est aussi et tous mis
on a trouvé un traitement qui donne
quand même des résultats mais on est
quand même à plus de 70 mille morts on
est quand même avec un chaos total aux
états unis que vous avez dont vous êtes
fait l'écho certainement et là ça prend
des proportions qui sont inquiétantes
d'autant que et merci de ma vie t on
peut pas dire à une population il faut
vous vacciner et de ne pas avoir en
stock ni les vaccins ni organisation
alors je veux bien ça fait ça fait 15
jours qu'on discute mais mais là si vous
voulez quand d'un coup on vous dit on
vaccine pu en première intention parce
qu'on n'aura pas assez de doses pour
vacciner les deuxièmes que vous voyez ce
qui se passe que d'un coup vous
apprenait ce matin que les chaînes de
production qui pourrait être maître mise
au service de la production de vaccins
en france ce qui nous garantit la
souveraineté il va falloir attendre deux
mois de validation de la technostructure
pour valider
ces chaînes c'est assez agaçant en fait
ce inquiétant parce que ce que j'ai vu
et je participe aux vaccinations sur sur
l'hôtel-dieu à paris
c'est des gens qui commencent à
s'énerver mais gens qui commencent à y
aller à la castagne parce que
contrairement à ce qu'on a fait croire
aux gens les gens veulent le vaccin
parce qu'ils ont compris l'intérêt
notamment les plus âgés les plus
notamment de 50 ans bon et ça pose un
problème parce que si vous voulez vous y
à il ya deux fronts à mener en même
temps il ya le front sur la maladie ou
la vraiment les hôpitaux on est à genoux
ça vous aura pas échappé que l'élan qui
avait au mois de mars qui était assez
conviviale et assez festif on nous
applaudissaient tout ça tout ça ça a
disparu c'est pas le problème c'est
juste qu'une adhésion collective de
cette adhésion collective a été remplacé
par un ras-le-bol qu'on partage tout ce
qu'on partage chances d'accord
et puis de l'autre il ya le vaccin et le
vaccin pose vraiment quelque chose
d'important là derrière vous il ya les
chiffres et c'est exact ça monte de tous
les côtés et et c'est pour ça et juste
pour terminer il ya vraiment
l'importance des gestes barrières qu'il
faut rappeler et on va pas pouvoir si
ceux-ci cette saloperie de virus mute
d'année en année cyril on va pas pouvoir
concevoir une société qui va rester
confinés et où on va vivre comme ça moi
c'est ça c'est pas possible à ce qu'on
se dit patrick c'est que on va confie
néons var confiné on va d confiné on va
en fait on va et on a plus de délai
passé ça donc c'est plus possible donc
d'un coup il ya quand même on est
quelques-uns à dire aux pouvoirs publics
notamment au président de dire écoutez
va falloir reconcevoir la société et la
civilisation sur des nouvelles bases
parce que et ça je suis d'accord avec
vers ans qui l'a dit aujourd'hui
influencé par blanc caire et j'adhère
complètement
on ne peut pas arrêter les écoles parce
qu'il ya eu une alerte des
pédopsychiatres si on arrête les écoles
les enfants se désocialise et on a un
gros problème il ya des enfants qui sont
pas retournés à l'école depuis le mois
de mars dernier mais vagues et châteaux
parcs
alors les enfants alors je vous dis
arrêté l'école très important de ne pas
arrêter les écoles c'est très important
pour les raisons vous avez expliqué moi
j'entends aussi
ou d'adultes qui sont en extrême
dépression parce qu'on voit plus
personne
ils sont chez eux ici et ça c'est aussi
un gros gros danger est énorme
télétravail là ça devient nous avons la
leyre étudiants aussi nous avons là
l'herbe des pédopsychiatres nous avons
la leyre des psychiatres mais nous avons
jamais fait autant de suicide chez les
adolescents pour ce qui est du samu de
paris
d'accord laissez les centres médico
psychologiques sont débordés on a une
augmentation d'à peu près de 20% des
psychotropes faut qu'on fasse tenir les
gens c'est à dire c'est de la culture de
masse je veux bien qu'on nomme des
supers scientifique bardé de diplômes
que je respecte par dessus tout qui sont
formidables
le problème c'est qu'on est sûr de la
gestion de masse on est là on est sur le
fait qu'on a une population qui est en
souffrance que là on en oublie vous
savez le principal fléau tout ça c'est
la solitude
on a abandonné des gens c'est facile de
vous confiné quand vous êtes dans un
logement adéquat c'est très difficile
quand vous êtes 5 dans vingt mètres
carrés et on a oublié tout ça et on a
laissé échapper une société là ce qui
est en train de se passer
si ce virus mute ça veut dire que
l'année prochaine il nous la joue pareil
ah oui ça veut dire qu'il va falloir
qu'on trouve de nouveaux vaccins ça veut
dire qu'on ne peut pas continuer à dire
on bloque la culture on bloque les cafés
on bloque les restaurants on bloque la
vie ça veut dire une réflexion d'union
nationale en effet ça reprend les termes
du président de la république du mois de
mars faut fair nation je suis totalement
d'accord on fait nation mais on se met
d'accord sur une ligne on peut pas
continuer comme ça il ya vraiment une
souffrance de la population et de dire
aux gens il faut vous vacciner
et quand ils font l'effort d'aller sur
des sites internet qui ne marche pas
d'accord elle de faire des numéros
d'appel qui marche rarement d'aller
faire la queue dans le froid pour se
faire vacciner qu'on leur dit bah on a
plus de doses il ya un ras-le-bol énorme
qui est en train de monter tu comprends
que c'est de cette façon mais patrick
alors là quelle est la solution parce
que ce que ce couvre-feu de 18h il sert
à quelque chose ou pas du tout alors il
a diminué et il essaye en fait la
stratégie c'est qu'ils essayent de
diminuer l'impact de la contamination
d'accord là
en fait c'est un échec c'est un échec
donc le confort qu'on veut c'est un
échec le couvre-feu est quasiment un
échec
bon on va pas c'est vraisemblablement je
suis convaincu au confinement dans
l'es15 les quinze prochains jours les
parents de janvier février
voilà bon je suis pas très content quand
tu parles de confinement ça va être un
confinement comme on a connu en mars où
les écoles pour l'heure encore ouverte
les écoles resteront ouvertes je pense
que ça c'est acquis pour justement pour
les enfants pour permettre aux enfants
de se développer et on n'a pas ça je
reprends vraiment un
on a surveillé ça pour ce qui est de
paris et nul de francs sont à surveiller
ça avec l' agence régionale il n'y a pas
eu de foyers de contamination au niveau
des écoles d'accord ça il ya un journal
qui a fait sa une en disant attention
aux cantines
non c'est faux on n'a pas vu ces cas là
vraiment je vous le dirai d'accord on
les a pas eu le même de l'accord on les
a pas eu ce bon donc d'un coup on peut
garder donc ça voudrait dire un
confinement du type du mois d'octobre
novembre
voilà un accord c'est ça mais ce que je
voudrais dire c'est que vous pouvez
jouer un confinement si un deal c'est
donnant donnant je vous fais le
confinement mais pendant le confinement
joue vaccine c'est ça certes ils vont
faire et c'est ce qu'ils sont restés en
israël
c'est ce qu'ils sont en beauté en israël
c'est ce qu'ils arrivent à faire en
israël
voilà c'est ce qu'ils arrivent à faire
dans d'autres pays là on a dépassé les 5
millions de vaccinés en angleterre les
centres de vaccination h 24 mai 7 jours
sur 7
nous il va falloir un moment donné qu'on
fasse la même chose c'est pour ça qu'à
mon avis à un médecin général de l'armée
qui gérait la vaccination la gestion de
là ça serait mieux qu un fondamentaliste
sur les virus si vous voyez ce que je
veux dire
mais j'ai rien contre lui mais c'est
juste un truc pratico pratique et jeu et
je suis convaincu que le conseil
scientifique
j'en connais une partie sont super etc
mais je pense qu'ils sont grillés je
pense qu'il faut faire balles neuves
il faut qu'il y ait de nouvelles équipes
carillon qu'elles ont la tête dans le
guidon oui si je suis un an maintenant
ou moi c'est normal je cela je sors de
garde cette nuit j'ai 24 ans et je suis
hs je suis incapable de prendre en
charge un infarctus ce soir ça c'est
clair j'ai une équipe qui m'a remplacé
il n'y a pas de honte à eux je pense que
c'est pareil sur la gestion de la crise
s'est avancé parce que là on est à des
échéances qui sont vraiment majeurs mois
qui serait le pire c'est que d'un coup
j'ai plus d'adhésions collective par
rapport à ce que disent les autorités
scène de cela il ya plus de politique
derrière la gauche on sait plus où elle
est la droite on sait pas d'accord donc
vous n'avez pas ça qu'est ce qui restera
des émeutes ça mais ces femmes et des
insurrections ce que je dis on a tous à
y perdre c'est pour ça que là si vous
voulez il ya vraiment quand vous
entendez on a la possibilité de faire
des chaînes de production du vaccin en
france que vous avez des industriels
qu'est ce qu'on fait on attend des
valides euros par des technocrates qui
vont durer 12 mois ça la regarde voilà
croyable et vous avez mine de rien
patrick vous avez quand même une voix
qui porte
non vous êtes extrêmement écoutez je
comprends pas que l'on vous écoute pas
non non non non non non non non non non
c'est donc ces îles on est là on est en
eux c'est sympa vous êtes tous à doha
mais ça ça c'est ce que vous dites ça
c'est pas grand chose mais parce que
donc vous la solution et le coup de
gueule ou pas cessé vous pourrez trouver
confinement c'est à peu près sûr on va
le dire voilà dans dans dix jours vous
parle du 1er février
voilà c'est bien sûr à prendre au
conditionnel mais on y va tout droit
même olivier véran de l'apa voilà dit
tout à l'heure qu'il n'excluait pas un
confinement tout alors au jt de tf1
patrick donc j'aime bien voir cette idée
de donnant-donnant de deal avec et avec
avec avec la population avec les
français ce deal se serait on vous
confie d'un mois voilà mais vraiment
sérieux voilà et pendant ce temps là on
bosse on vous fait les vaccins ouais on
vous prépare ses dires et vous savez qui
aurait cru il ya deux ans on l'aurait
dit écoutez le peuple français on va
leur mettre des masques
on va leur mettre la distanciation
physique on va leur mettre du j'aimerais
on va leur dire vous pouvez plus sortira
le 18 arrête tout mais plus belles ouest
et si vous avez ça va sûrement bien sûr
que les impôts s'il ya une adhésion
konan qui restera d'accord il ya eu un
côté fédérateur nous sommes un peuple
vaillant fait nous sommes un peuple
intelligent on comprend les choses faire
un troisième confinement sans deal sans
dire écoutez on vous confie mais on va
vous vacciner
peut-être pas dans la loi mais vous
aurez tel rendez-vous à telle heure
a du sens ce que font les états unis là
ils sont séparés de leurs fous c'est
très bien la iso byden qu'est ce qu'il a
fait il est en train de dire on va
vacciner massivement
il met tout son côté il ya même amazon
qui a dit je m'occupe de la distribution
des vaccins
why not d'accord nous on n'est pas comme
ça mais on a des chaînes de production
qui peuvent faire le vaccin et il ya un
des freins administratifs
vous savez le préfet le président de la
république ils ont la possibilité de
déroger à tout ça et de réquisitionner
leur d'heure en heure armée mais qu'il
le phare mais bon sens qu'ils le fassent
alors 9 ristic leleu vous nous parler du
variant il faut aller vite très très
vite c'est à dire c'est bon c'est quoi
le quand vous dites vis de ça veut dire
quoi on y monte il ya il ya trois
semaines il est à 1 % on a dépassé les
5% là sur les contaminations
il va très très vite en fait si vous
voulez tout la notion de fermeture des
frontières c'est trop tard d'accord
d'accord retard s'il est là c'est qu'il
est là faut réaffirmer les gestes
barrière faut redire qu on surveille
alors si vous voulez là c'est la
différence c'est l'opposition entre la
gestion de masse et de santé publique ou
en fait il faut gérer la maladie et
potigny à la gérer et les sciences
fondamentales qui sont en train de nous
dire ah mais pour chaque malade va
falloir tester et c'est ça on en a pas
trop les capacités et pas trop les
moyens
soit dit en passant mais en gros ce
qu'on sait c'est que le virus brésilien
est déjà en france le virus sud
africains et les juges en france le
virus anglais alors là et déjà aidé à
pousser ça qu'il faut qu'on gère et là
dans les hôpitaux
bah on est déjà déjà très très serré là
cette nuit c'est excessif vous étiez on
a eu vingt pourtant on a on avait je te
jure on avait zéro pourcent d'activité
quasiment decaux vide au cours pendant
noël etc
on n'avait pas 20 % cette nuit ça va
monter en puissance
c'est nos inquiétudes parce que pendant
qu'on parle du coronavirus il ya tous
les autres bien sûr il ya tous les
autres malades
d'accord et ça c'est inquiétant on a 60
% de retard sur les coloscopies ce qui
veut dire qu'il ya des tas de cancer qui
sont en train de céder des actifs qui
sont en train de grimper de ton n'a pas
détecté
nous avons du retard sur les accidents
vasculaires cérébraux sur les infarctus
des gens qui ne veulent
allez à l'hôpital nous en avons encore
notamment les personnes âgées disent je
ne veux pas alors évidemment c'est assez
simple parce que maintenant il faut
signer une décharge mais vous vous dites
si on l'emmène à l'hôpital on le sauve
il signa des charges puisque maintenant
la loi leur permet ils disent non je
veux pas me faire soigner
voilà on est on est à halak à la croisée
des chemins
là il n'y a jamais eu autant d'enjeux en
termes à la fois de santé en termes de
santé qui veut dire médicale
psychologique et sociétales et et c'est
pour ça que là il faut vraiment qu'ils
comprennent ça alors je comprends bien
chez morandini ce matin j'ai eu un débat
sur avec une députée la république en
marche qui est pas
je comprends ce qu'elle dit elle défend
tout ce qu'ils font et c'est mais sans
que les caméras sont coupées et qu'on
discute
elle me dit non mais vous avez raison il
ya des blocages administratifs y sont
nos pratiques sont incroyables mais des
blocs on les a bien sûr dans des
brocolis yahia qu'il ya probablement
encore révélant des rendez vous avec eux
vous avez déjà rencontré deux minutes de
la santé ou président de la république
ou le premier ministre et premier
ministre régulièrement président je
pense que il sait ce que je dis pas ce
que les nôtres monte emily's l'a senti
là il a beaucoup de travail mais voilà
c'est c'est c'est plus compliqué que ça
si c'était juste des entrevues et juste
la facilité de parler là ça serait
facile
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué que ça
actuellement